Here are some basic investment ideas that might help you.
The first idea suggests that you should increase your stocks when young by borrowing money.
You should borrow one dollar for every one dollar of your own money.
It is safe because young people have many years of future salaries ahead.
Secondly, people think that buying stocks is a good long-term option, yet this is not always true.
Japanese investors know all about this.
Thirdly, pertain to index funds.
Traditionally, you overweighed overvalued stocks and underweighed undervalued stocks.
With "fundamental indexing," you should do the reverse.
Number four talks about "momentum investors", people who chase hot investments.
It's better to rank stocks by how they performed over one year rather than follow a "hot" tip...
...that foresees some excellent future prospects.
Lastly, commodities futures are in vogue because of inflation worries, but you should be skeptical.
Once they become more popular, their returns could fall.